citizens of the reject Nation we are here
to continue the coast Rider franchise with
spirit of Vengeance yeah how are you I'm good
how are you I'm doing good we have never seen
this movie guys if you didn't catch Tara's first
time watching and my first time re-watching in
like 20 years or whatever the first one came
out that is up here on the channel now we get
to experience this together I hear this one is
weird weird I have seen a couple of the movies
these directors have made have you seen the crank
movies yes it's these guys okay so we might be a
little okay if you've seen them that gives us
a little bit of leeway to be a tad prepared
for the kind of style I don't know if I've
seen the entire movie Crank but I have seen
a scene that stuck in my head like crank came
out in like 2005 right like it's old movie yeah
okay then I think I've seen some of it but not
the whole thing and yes okay I'm with the vibe
now let's do it so guys leave a like that would
be very much appreciated also ring the bell
ring the bell ring the bell ring it and also
uh full length Direction watch along where you
sync with your own copy of spirit of Vengeance
available for super sexy Rejects at our patreon
page muchas gracias to all who have joined our
patreon page thus far and uh cover several things
exclusive over there with highlights and watch
Longs included let's get to it rejack Nation
[Music]
there's that frenetic energy
are those monks
that's it yourself I did not know
he was in this the Devil Himself was
one place that is safe that is the sanctuary in
a few days the winter solstice will be passed
and with it the hour of the prophecy and the
boy will give no use to anyone oh it's the
guy from Buffy they both work together
in a TV show and I don't know the name
wow [Applause]
to hell
so there's they're after a boy [Music]
oh [Music] I can help you he's trying
to help you I must take you to the ghost
whoa that was a cool shot where are they
shut up
what that guy was barely in this room [Music]
[Laughter]
some cool shots in here
what okay
that's like a video game nice shot bro [Music]
oh that's awesome my name is Johnny Blairs
yeah you see my motorcycle for a living I did
a bare ass 360 triple back flip in front of 22
000 people this is like spider-verse yeah
but when my dad got sick I did something
way crazier than that you look like you
could use a little help are you willing to
they're redoing the origin wow yeah or save
his life I'm the guy who made the deal with
possessed by an ancient demon and I pray on the
wicked I love these visuals I try to find it but
the darkness inside me only gets stronger
that's why I had to run this is cool man
and I'm still running that's an
awesome intro where's Roxanne
my brothers are dead as should I be if not for
the intervention of God oh my God [Laughter]
saved by a tree
it likes the Dark Places I don't know what you're
talking about oh no it's taking
over his just Johnny Blaze life
oh why are you here I need your help and you
need your soul so we make a deal we know about
making deals don't you Johnny oh he does I mean
the devil now you no problem you who's Evian
I know save people what brought
you out here thousands of miles
from your place of birth and your dark
rebirth this wait is a shot is so kinetic
this man that you met years ago that put the curse
on you yeah link that connects you to this child
bring us the boy and we will lift your curse oh no
you don't want that we don't want that what's up
what the hell
whoa that is demented
cool shot look I got people after Danny
and me so just let me go I'm the people
this guy's a prick seems like a real slimy jerk
oh my God all right you're just gonna like oh my
God to it kid stop that kid's face yeah to a kid
Let's Ride
heck yeah
yeah whoa this is a there's some
really cool shots in this man
ready whoa
oh he already looks way more
rad yeah it's more hellish
yeah I was like what do we do
nicely dude
I like how it actually looks like a skull that
yeah burnt to a crisp it looks like real yeah
what just happened
[Music]
he's really taking his time this Johnny
Blaze look at it yeah is he singing all
the bad history soul sucking right now oh
my God is his head gonna explode [Music]
wow it did
oh did the little boy do that I think the little
boy did that really yeah with his drop of blood
oh okay that worked a little bit get some stuff
get him in the car he's
like protecting the boy now
yo Ghost Rider what happened back there yeah come
on man it's been way too much time
just just milking it melting that
guy's brain when really you just could
have like turned him to Ash real quick
look at this although they just treat this
little kid like [__] it's like so much kids
deserve it I got your package but the guys
are doing business with me just went up we
had an agreement Carrigan changing the defined
terms of agreement is something we just don't do
that looks like a young Kurt Russell yes thank
you that was bothering me three of my guys got
turned into matchsticks last night by a dude on a
motorcycle with his head on fire come again I've
seen things weird things bad things that's a
cool transition what I want you very closely
Kill Them All [Music] I just uploaded
a little program firewall a friend
on the motorcycle won't be able to
sense him now that explains for me
this movie isn't like disorienting or nauseating
it looks really cool yeah it looks dope flip flops
between like so many times like two this
is really awesome so many camera angles
you tracked us why you do it again I could feel
them before I could sense them and then nothing
no no he's not dead he's just blocked
off it's like a firewall he's offline man
when Nick is like just free roaming crazy path
that's when he found me you promised to take
the pain away but he asked for something in
return you're the devil's baby mama huh hell
yeah why does the devil walk on earth in human
form anyway maybe just passes on from body to body
down through history waiting for the perfect fit
oh my God on Earth he's weak his powers
are limited he needs emissaries to do
his dirty work so he finds them
or makes them using his greatest
power handshake the deal yeah AKA a
handshake the power of a handshake
can I open a window do you think you can just
talk you know your mom thought she could just talk
until I could go Gypsy faces it's just a window
yeah I mean definitely time for these guys to die
yeah kid oh damn oh all right it's a good thing he
buckled up that ensures are
gonna be just fine safety
thank you
so dark and gritty I don't
know dude what happened yeah
oh
what do they do to those other
guys yeah why do we get to see
them kill them man that's the guy it
looks like it works on a cruise ship
[Music]
I got it this is like
drugged out so high right now
long time idea you look good oh
he's so on edge I love it last couple of days
and a few hours ago whoa oh whoa all right John
oh my goodness for you and the rider is me
he's just whoa he's gripping at the door
I'm gonna let him out
this is awesome together I know
the place John gotta go we gotta go
yeah I am all here for Nicolas Cage's
dude oh my gosh me too here for it
it's all right thank you
cool cool shot oh my goodness
oh my God
this looks like a metal music video yeah
oh yeah
I just love how unstable he is he's off his
rocker man this one feels like it could be
R-rated yeah and why is it PG-13 yeah
I'm sorry I'm gonna get you out of here
just try kissing her making out
real quick before he kills her
oh
all right smart so I always bring a gun to a
knife fight give me that thing give it to me
what the tracker missile
laughs
like Harry's like a monster
oh [__] oh
what
what what is he doing how where did he learn that
just eating bullets oh my God
he's gonna barf him up awesome
oh that backfired
oh [__] that's rad
what did he just convert this whole thing I
love it I love it this is like nightmare fuel
[Music]
holy [__]
nice how does this guy keep surviving
I mean this is when you start running
away from him because you oh what I
yeah a hands gun is gonna do it now
just kill him Ghost Rider yeah come on just
do it we all know he won't though I really
feel like you really get the sense of Nicholas
Cage playing the Ghost Rider this time yeah yeah
don't hurt her what what it's like
split personalities Let Her Go
oh damn he was supposed to save him but he's the
new enemy oh my gosh is he
like his arch nemesis now
that happened what
happened to be I thought I was
gonna sting your face [Laughter]
so what's next well morose seems to think that
the days will pass in a few days if we could just
get Danny someplace safe I've already contacted
Monroe he's going to catch up with us on the road
road the road
you're not done Carrie again
yeah be kidding me no way
oh he knows how to
huh
what the hell's going on oh what
oh what Reborn who how when why
oh my God he looks terrifying feral
oh
so he lost a little bit of Decay power giving
it to him because I mean he looks messed up now
is it anything he touches
whoa that looks awesome the
machine you made it change
that's how it works whenever he rides
changes with him hey what if you have to
pee while you're on fire huh that's awesome
it's like a flamethrower you know it's like
oh my God that was that was so dumb
oh my God that's great what is this
this power that we have comes from a dark place
but it's not who we are and we can use it to
do good like I'm helping you and your mom I
know why you're helping us so Disturbed she
says you want to get rid of it you want to
have some fun [Music] why not hang on whoa
[Music]
there are some cool bike stunts
[Applause] this is so strange
I'm here for it the weirder it gets the better
yeah well is he toasting in the cup yeah oh I
got it I love it how can he drive but he can't
touch bread what are the rules here to the decay
amen he looks familiar
you mustn't be afraid it was God that led you
here that's Christopher Lambert have you seen
Mortal Kombat yeah he's raid in Highlander oh I
couldn't see him through all the tats you're safe
I'm sure that will never happen the exposure
in this Scene It seems highly filtered
what is it staying inside
him it was an angel a spirit of Justice are we
redoing the origin of just rewriting
it brought down to Hell corrupted
well driven in sand experimental he became the
spirit of versions but the angel Spirit of Justice
he's alive in there you could awaken him
you must confess the one thing that is
most difficult for you to talk about his dad my
dad went into it for him I couldn't let him go
it was selfish I'm sorry I'm full of tears
this is the Lamb of God the bread of Christ
we are those that are called to receive him you
say that you are not worthy to receive him I'm not
oh that's great
that's delicious been carrying this bread around
they cannot follow are you ready
oh no is this tomb where Jesus was buried and on
the third day he rose again Greg is it Easter yet
[Music]
is this like an exorcism
he's exercising it out what
okay so
so depraved this movie's tiring me out man
once the ringer with this movie boxing match
[Laughter] we're both gonna need a nap after this
get back
you need to welcome the spirit
of Vengeance back in you
what will be done they gotta get rid of the devil
we got to hold the boy until the danger passes
this boy exists power always be inside
him this child must be destroyed nah man
what are they gonna chop off his head
little boy use your powers my
goodness yeah have him machete
all the guys around you all their heads come off
yeah cool cool
oh uh good thing Decay guys here
what a cruel way to die whoa
oh God wow oh that's gnarly
whoa look at how they look I look like statues
ah the juxtaposition of life and death yeah so
now he's with Rorke some protectors you turned
out to be what exactly does Rog have in mind the
child must be in his 13th year before the red
can be performed on the dawn of a new winter the
right what does that mean Rock father the boy is
a vessel as a container for his power the ritual
will transform his Essence his soul into the boy
do you know where work has them I think so
yes well by so now you want to play Hero
but I promise Danny he'd be safe and if I walk
away now I'm just trading one demon for another
it's gonna do without the writer there's no way
he's got to go back in the Tomb and like get
it back right he can't just be rolling in him
and Nick Cage in it Danny do you know who I am
I love this guy who's there that is where the
ritual is to take place so I think we should have
weapons sweet oh cool cool holy people his
body I'm living in it's weak but you at Orioles
can wield the power without burning
itself up I like his performance yeah
slimy and creepy who are they politicians
murderers people of influence the devil's soldiers
look at this Sound Stage Danny's soul
will be lost forever at the break of dawn
I've made a lot of mistakes place Danny's one
good thing I ever did he's the son of the devil
hey hang it in there Tara I was just thinking like
if she had him and the devil's baby doesn't she
still have a little bit of devil in her and she
could use it to her power like it's a good theory
what about you
not bad
might be good on a salad oh my God [Music]
what's a waste of good wine
he's just gonna grab him from there
uh uh freaky
come on oh fight it
oh no no oh
it's too easy he's gonna race you Danny
whoa
uh that can still see the light [Music]
oh whoa damn cool you're nothing but
an insect food for the Mills of hell
gosh that looked it looked like just just a hand
yeah oh man how can he get his power back this is
not for my powers and years are the same you
said gonna give him the Ghost Rider powers
do it
oh wow
oh my gosh [Music]
heck yeah he's back baby
oh [__]
gotta War Maneuvers right there
okay
oh man he doesn't cut through the asphalt
anymore it's cool seeing this in the daytime
[Music]
oh his face looks insane
cool
Wilhelm so if you just jump
and scream out of fear out
of the truck I love how you could just
convert all these vehicles fire truck
[Applause]
whoa [Music]
this mother ah this guy start swerving lady
at the Briggs kid real hard come here
cool
[Music]
I like the shifting of perspectives
oh [Applause] unbelievable
oh
I was never afraid of you
[Music] do the patents there
what it was that quick he just did it
what are you just roadkill oh my God
cool shot
[Music]
oh oh geez whoa you're gonna kill the boy
oh my God you yes I'm saving you James a
little boy you think that through buddy they
managed to pull off these visuals during the
daytime you normally can't like to get
Ghost Rider in the day it's hard yeah
does a lot of screaming and
faces and deal ever made
go
oh [Music]
my goodness right now love it
all right
he's like a monster animal this time
like the jittery movement
the kids got to be still alive right
save money on the transformation bro since
the writer was an angel that went crazy
healed heal
yeah now let him do it
give him some Angel juice oh snap that was really
much of a moment uh that was very quick barely
touched him yeah could the angel even get in
there that quick did we win I'm gonna say yeah
hell yes okay my name is Johnny
Blaze oh New Life [Laughter]
the angel Ghost Rider now
wow
my eyes hurt
well if they're saying to watch something they're
saying what if they're suggesting another movie
that must mean that's no post
credits okay oh wow my eyes hurt
uh-huh I feel like I need a cold press
yeah that's one way to put it oh God
take it away Tara oh wow me first huh yeah you go
first Tara I really liked it um the style of like
I always think it's crazy how two directors can
work together find a style like this with a DP and
then an editor who's like absolutely no know what
to do with all of this because you go from like
over the head shot to like dolly in on somebody's
face and then it's a close-up but I'd like two
frames to come together and then go out and it's
just one wide frame but then it comes back into
a close-up like it's insane and definitely is
kind of made like one was this made like into
early 2000s like it's kind of made for like today
with social media how nobody can like if the shot
doesn't change every seven seconds this movie
is like re-release release now on tick tock
will be like rather forever yeah um I really liked
it though I liked I thought that he was going I
thought he was gonna have to go back in the Tomb
and like change back on his own volition but uh I
like that the kid gave him the the power at the
end it was rooted in love yeah I like that uh
and also just Nick Cage's monologue gave me so
much joy when he is high on drugs and he just
gives that whole monologue to that guy uh that
just that made my life yeah I would like that
to play over and over in the background on my TV
when I'm doing anything I think the first movie
is overall in total a better movie agreed
because it's got like a real movie to it
it also has what's his nuts Who is fantastic
the guy that we kept saying Yeah Yeah
but this doesn't feel like a sequel to that movie
at all no it's like they made it it's like they
made it their own they like you were saying in
the beginning it's like they rewrote the even
the beginning that the origin story because
that first movie ends off on he's gonna be a
hero and he's gonna go after Mephisto the devil
and then here it's like we're doing a completely
separate movie we're doing something entirely
different this time around and there's things
about this though that I that I do prefer like
a lot like not not even like by a small margin I
mean there's things that aesthetically that
I really dug so much like whatever it was
um you know in Ghost Rider form the visuals of
that that kinetic frenzy nature and it also like
the texture to it felt more real and tangible
yeah versus uh you know the first movie where
it did look like CGI white skull thing yeah I like
the aesthetic they went for like it looked like a
crisp skull like the skull that was like it burned
off his flesh and this is this is his skeleton
nature of it um and I thought there was a lot of
great visuals to it and especially with the action
scenes of like converting the vehicles the many
times yeah I I thought there was a lot of really
cool uh orchestrated shots overall it's just
that what it wasn't with Ghost Rider or Nick Cage
the pacing of It kind of weighed the movie down
for me a little bit like when it was when it was
Nick Cage it was so fun it was such a blast and I
was like I might prefer this more just because of
like how crazy unhinged he is but you spend
like half the movie with these other people
who are kind of boring yeah and uninteresting
and at least with the first movie you're mainly
with Nicholas Cage who's giving a very different
performance very different uh yeah like and that
one he's like I'm playing a relatable hero yeah
here he's like I'm playing okay that's so great
um so yeah I mean people set us up that this is
like oh man it's kind of not good but I there's a
lot about it that I actually liked uh quite a bit
and like you I'm actually appreciative of of the
overall aesthetic and style and the wackiness that
this movie has to offer yeah I I actually think
that it was in her it would fluctuate at times it
was like okay this is a bit tedious too this is
really engaging but it never stayed only tedious
right I never stayed only engaging like it would
it would dip in and out literally from beginning
to end and in the shots too yeah it would be a
different thing if I was here going it'd be a
different thing if it was like oh this is fun and
then like the last half is just right yeah yeah
it just kept flipping in and out uh throughout
so because of the fact that like at least more
than half of it was like fun and weird in ways
that were like I don't know like him him peeing
fire I'm like it's so bizarre what but I like it
also Jerry Springer yeah oh with the animation
visuals those are amazing those those provided
a a really cool uh life to it like the yeah the
first one plays it safe in what it's going for
like it's well done and it's got a cool like PG-13
Supernatural Aura to it and this one goes like so
dark yeah and so more and so Tower like it goes
so dark to the point that it kind of strips away
some of the fun but at times the movie is really
fun yeah but it's like it's you're right with like
the the tone and the pacing of like when there's
jokes in there when it's like uh what it was like
roadkill and then the the guy the guy that turned
his hair blonde yeah he said some funny line on
the ground I don't even remember what it was but
it was obviously meant to be like a comedic line
we're gonna add in and I was like ah I don't know
if it feels like right now if that's gonna work or
if it should I was like oh should they have just
played it yeah in that moment just seriously where
I don't know he's mad and he's his powers are
taken away I I forget the joke he made so I'm
not I'm not making a good point Point here but you
guys understand that there's like times when that
came up and I was like I can laugh at it for sure
I just it wasn't like hahaha genuinely funny to
me because I kind of would get wrapped up in the
story of like where is this actually going like is
this is this freaking guy like gonna die already
the the d uh decomposing decaying guy thank you
like when he came up in the beginning that was a
little bit when the story slowed down I saw him
once and then when you continue to see him with
weapons and people and all of their guns give me
a bigger weapon round two and you're like guys
haven't you learned your lesson like just get
out of there this guy you can't kill him uh
it's just funny to me that they they didn't
think to like add in I don't know a little bit
of a conversation of like he doesn't die via
weapons so can we try something else like just
skip to it like then somebody else like sign a
deal with the devil and be like you gotta mess me
up now forever so I can kill the Ghost Rider yeah
yeah I think that they're never going to make
it okay 2012 is when this came out they're never
again they're never going to make it but the
perfect film would have been a part three that
is a hybrid of the first one yes and this one
like amazing yeah something that goes for the
incredibly dark manic bleakness craziness but also
manages to be a real movie yeah it manages to be
like have because the relationships in the first
one are better I believed them more I felt it more
there was more of a heart yeah to it but it also
does play it like Ghost Riders superhero you know
like we don't wanna we don't want to cry whereas I
liked how like um malevolent and and um a freaking
crazy unhinged the actual Ghost Rider is like yeah
he really is this deranged monster and I like this
soul that they gave him here like there's that
how it was uh and Angel who got corrupted and
like they did like experimental torture to him
and it's a so it's an angel who was corrupted not
because it was tempted by evil but was tortured
you know yeah I I like how they captures that
tortured spirit and I I feel like the Ghost Rider
and the first one could have been played by I'm
not talking about Johnny Blaze I'm talking about
the ghost writer itself could have been played
by anyone like any stun double or mocap actor
yes where here I really got the sense that it
was Nick Cage doing it yeah like you could feel
Nick Cage in the performance so I I like it and I
prefer the Johnny overall I actually prefer this
Johnny Blaze who is who is just so like intense
yeah yeah like it's it's such a he's uncomfortable
in his own skin in every moment I I like that uh
so that's what I mean there's a lot about this
that I actually prefer that I that I enjoyed
and I think the perfect movie would have been
some blend of what the first one was doing with
this one uh yeah and to get is Sam Elliott him to
fight together what in the F like I still think
about that all the time I'm like I wish I could
see that fight they really dropped like a lot of
like the Penance there yeah yeah that's such a big
thing in the first one yeah to the point where it
actually feels like they dialed back some of the
Ghost Rider's Powers here you know what I mean yes
right right yeah it's it's except they bumped him
up with like the visual and I think in in making
this like when you said you're like how do they
storyboard this so I'm like yeah they must have
had to like be like we need a million animators
to like draw this out to make it look insane
um but specifically to make the Ghost Rider
more tangible like uh more palpable like
just when you look at him you're like
heck yeah like I am on board with it
um and all of the visuals were really really
awesome but I do agree it was missing a little bit
of the heart no matter how hard they tried to like
that one moment where they're like let's just have
the kid at the diner look at another kid with his
dad and have Nick Cage notice it and then wipe try
to wipe his hair with the same like I'm like what
Nick I I don't I was like this seems like a forced
moment can there be anything written a little bit
better that wasn't like oh there was a bee in your
hair you couldn't feel it like some crazy bike
stuff like what yeah like that didn't it it was
it was obvious what they were trying to do but it
wasn't delivered in the in the right way for me to
feel it well the movie doesn't breathe yeah it's
just this it once the engine starts it is pretty
much this one pace throughout and and every scene
that needs a moment to just really like slow down
and breathe yeah because I'm all for the style
when it was doing the action scenes but it needed
to breathe for like emotional momency yes so you
could get attached to something because I was
like I don't feel any Stakes happening here
despite the fact that I am enjoying what is
before both like right holding my eyes right now
you know yeah so yeah it was it was uh it was a
fascinating experience I agree overall though yeah
no room's fun it was fun it's a lot of fun it was
fun but but it was like my eyeballs are kind of
hurting now yeah because because there's nothing
happening in my heart right now other than when
I'm laughing with something that's cool that's
happening but there was there were some genuinely
cool stuff here but it sucks we'll never get a
part three yeah I feel like that's why I didn't
like the whole movie I had I couldn't say anything
I just was like I was like that like mouth a gap
Agape however people say it and just staring at
this green the entire time like I don't I was very
engulfed in like what is gonna happen next because
the screen is always changing but I'm like I was
really like when are they gonna oh it's gonna
come don't miss a cut because you never know you
could miss him turning into the angel in a second
um but I did like you said the devil guy
at the very end if he would have been more
throughout this movie even though he was there
but it was only touches of him it was more the
other decaying guy that I thought the devil was
he's a great actor I forget his name but like he
he was great and and very very believable in that
that maybe I don't know it would it wouldn't have
felt as tedious if maybe he was more in it and we
didn't cut back to them trying so much to kill him
the same way with like bullets and cannons yeah
that they would have tried a different technique
like just show us something different that you've
used like your brain and your weird devil powers
like the decaying thing is cool like great I gave
you Powers see what you can do now cool got it
um it just took us a little while to get there I
think of them trying the same way to kill him and
I I just thought man there's got to be something
more creative here especially with the way the
there it's animated the way that it's cut and
edited that they weren't like let's just play
with something else like how else could we
kill him that doesn't have to do with like
um like I don't know I'd be like I'm gonna fly a
helicopter and see if the blades can like cut off
his head like I don't this seems like that movie
that would try something like that like uh instead
of guns and cannons and all that yes there's
no Stakes when you're doing guns against Ghost
Rider right like you just like come on guys yeah
yeah I like but what about like drowning him or
like like weird stuff yeah right well when he does
kill them with like the chain I love the look in
this so awesome it's like yes I know you haven't
played God of War but it is like it is kind of
like a video game where it's just the way the the
the the efficiency the swiftness oh yeah so cool
but they're also like this it's striking yeah yeah
it looked really beautiful at the very end when he
killed kills all of the monks not that killing
the monks looks beautiful but there is a shot
from up above and he takes the chain and it's like
goes through the whole crowd of them that looked
awesome like a piece of art artwork yeah yeah uh
but movie definitely needed some uh a little heart
a heart and I like Idris Elba overall yeah I mean
I always love it yourself in anything isn't it I
love how he just looks like Idris Elba and how and
like even his costume is like how he dresses in
like every other movie yeah except he just has
a different accent this time yeah what was his
accent and he had contacts on I don't know what
his accent was it was like German French I don't
know maybe I don't know it was when he started
talking at first I was like oh okay we're doing
the accent thing here definitely picking it out of
that accident yeah that's that was the thing where
I was like why are we doing this and not just
having him yeah just talking to me his regular
voice which is already an accent but I don't think
he was like Superstar at rusalba the way he is now
no he was very much secondary character but what's
funny to me is that the guy that dies first and
we're like oh we like that guy the priest guy
that was with it in Buffy yes but I know and you
guys can leave it in the comments or something yes
they darn they in that show together Luther I've
never seen Luther I think they're in that show
together I haven't seen the whole thing I think
I watched like a season in my memory sucks but I
think that guy and Idris Elba work together all
the time on a TV series which I thought it's cool
because I'm like was this the first time they met
on Ghost Rider 2 and now they're working together
a lot more or am I just insane and I made that up
I don't know you guys can let me know the last
thing I think the sets could have been better
so like low budget oh interesting yeah except the
visuals looked [__] expensive as [__] yes but
were they shot everything just seemed like the
most empty Landscapes yeah you're you're that
you look like a fan like where you would shoot
on location for a fan film yes you know exactly
that's why I was like when you're like where are
they I was like Star Wars it looked like a like
you know the red Rocky like but with nothing
around it though like the it's like before set
deck got there and they were like well we're
gonna start with this and then they were like
yeah we're gonna just We're not gonna do anything
else just we're gonna like if there was actual
holes in the like in the canyons or whatever I
was like I think that's like probably all fake
but yes it was it wasn't as interesting which you
think that they would have put I guess more like
effort into it but were they just going along with
like no it's this is where the monks live there's
nothing around here like they're not supposed to
it's not supposed to be cool right I'm curious to
see what the budget is I wonder if part of the
deal was like we can bring this budget down oh
okay let's compare it Ghost Rider one production
budget what is the Ghost Rider one okay okay
110 million dollar budget for the first one okay
Ghost Rider spirit of Vengeance production budget
oh they cut it down by like 50 million dollars
yeah it definitely shows though like wow yeah
definitely yes it was a lot of like Street stuff
same location Cliffs and then it really is monk
stuff it looked very cheap were they shot I guess
you're right yeah I kind of wasn't registering it
because they uh I guess they did a good job with
just I mean cutting around it like when they're
not lot with a bunch of rocks and then he takes
the tractor and that's the first time we finally
get to see the tractor go on fire and that's
obviously all slightly animated CGI whatever
but it looked awesome but yeah I get you can
definitely do that with a cheaper like location
well cheap is good I suppose I wonder if
the movie made its money back still did
the gig still did the Jab radio people will
listen leave your nitpicks down below yeah
man that's what we ask you to do today
Tara RX and thank you so much for being
here thank you so much Greg Alba I said
his name right I tried to do it wrong
leave your thoughts down below did
you like this one or did you hate it
um subscribe click that Bell leave a like follow
Tara Rixon on go tub let's end this with a patron
of the day shout out let's do it Lance door Lance
is the perfect person to shout out okay Ghost
Rider because he's a firefighter now imagine
if you gave firefighter like Lance store the
powers of Ghost Rider he would show up put the
fires out and then before you know it he sets
the whole place on fire yes brand new fire I like
that all over again well you know that the best
way to fight fire though Gregory is with fire
and bullets yeah have you ever shot a fire it
was right out they gonna get scared it goes right
through it yeah I'm gonna die it goes straight to
hell it goes straight to hell you said the three
send the bullets so Lance you are the newly chosen
appointed spirit of Vengeance today buddy wow
lucky guy you're gonna go out there you're
gonna ride your motorcycle to that next fire to
put it out only to create an even bigger firing
chaos soon you'll be fired haha fire man who's on
fire who gets fired then you'll have to be on the
run then you'll go crazy just like Nick Cage here
because you will be unemployed yeah and also on
fire and also constantly on fire because you can't
seem to put then next thing you know you got bills
to pay you got to put out fires in your personal
life you lost your house you get a divorce your
kids are like my dad's on fire all the time
skip it you know what I mean it's tough it's
tough living but I think you can handle it door oh
your life will be physically and metaphorically on
fire at all times but you know what will not be on
fire your career it'll be drowning so Lance thanks
for being part of the patreon page happy to have
you here again you had another month buddy [Music]